on va revenir sur l'affaire Frédéric
bebéé d'ailleurs il avit vu hier Kelly a
eu un c'est sur les réseaux c'était un
truc de fou elle a eu c'est 50000 tweets
je crois y a eu 50000 tweets de gens qui
étaient d'accord avec ce ce qu'elle a
dit hier elle avait poussé un coup de
gueule puisque l'acteur de 58 ans une
relation avec Jun fi de de 17 ans après
c'était pas ça le souci en fait en fait
en tout cas au niveau de la loi c'éit
pas ça le souci elle parlait de la
morale voilà et et hier l'écrivain était
passé en garde à vue dans le cadre d'
enquête pour viol ce qui a fait
énormément réagir depuis quelques heures
c'est son communiqué ironique qu'il a
sorti derrière petit rap et ça ça a
l'air de prouver qu'il a l'air sûr de
lui en tout cas son communiqué hein Gill
regardez le recap de cette
affaire hier matin l'écrivain Frédéric
becbédé a été placé en garde à vue à
poau dans le cadre d'une enquête pour
viol après une plainte déposée cet été
par une jeune femme qui aurait entretenu
une relation avec lui elle affirme qu'il
qu'il l'a violé de de façon digitale et
si le romancier de 58 ans ni les faits
qui lui sont reprochés mon client se
montre parfaitement confiant en l'issue
de la procédure Frédéric becbd dont la
garde à vue a été levée hier en fin
d'après-midi a tenu à réagir quelques
heures plus tard à travers un communiqué
où il ironise sur la situation le poulet
au curry était sec et ma voiture s'est
retrouvée à la fourrière le temps d'une
garde à vue alors Frédéric becbédé fait
un communiqué ironique à sa sortie de
garde à vue s indescent s indescent
ouais s indescent ah bah Gill Verdez oui
c'est normal toujours Gill Verdez alors
je vais demander d'abord je je vais
demander d'abord à à Raymon tiens
d'abord c'est trop court c'est pas comme
ça qu'il dit il remercie la la police
c'est là c'est trop court les je vais le
redire parce que comme d'habitude c'est
toujours mal fait je remercie les
effectifs du commissariat de peau de
m'avoir accueilli dans leurs locaux
voilà c'est exactement ce qu'il a dit de
réserve cependant le poulet au curé
était sec et ma voiture s'est retrouvée
à la fourrière le temps d'une garde à
vue de quelques heures à peine il manque
décidément un parking devant ce
commissariat voilà donc c'est moi quand
j'ai quand j'ai lu ça c'est pour ça que
je non il s'en prend pas à la jeune
fille ça à voir avec l'affaire c'est
juste qu'il remercie les effectifs c'est
un communiqué c'est voilà c'est de
l'ironie et j'ai trouvé ça pour le coup
le le parking il manque un parking
dansant le commissariat j'ai trouvé ça
drôle donc je met non pour moi c'est pas
c'est pas mal placé il s'en prend pas il
s'en prend pas la jeune femme en fait
donc c'est deux choses différentes c'est
de l'humour il a fait de l'humour ça
c'est pas un communiqué c'est plus une
vanne en fait c'est le tonbd et lui dans
ses bouquins souvent il s'est un peu
indigné des dérives de Miou et là je
pense qu'il estime faire partie de ces
dérives il en a beaucoup parler dans
dans ces livres et il a le droit de dire
ça effectivement il y a pas de manque de
respect envers la victime présumée donc
il a le droit de le faire après tout il
s Pr donc g n'est pas d'accord je trouve
ça déplacé totalement déplacé et
indécent en fait il estime effectivement
vous le soullignez Cyril que la garde
àus est bien passée son avocat a demandé
des actes supplémentaires lui en son
fort intérieur il est persuadé que
l'affaire va en rester là il sera pas
mis en examin mais quel que soit l'issue
judiciaire il y a quand même une
plaignante je trouve ça indécent il est
quand même convoqué il est pas invité il
est pas accueilli il est convoqué pour
une affaire de viol je trouve que c'est
indécent ce communiqué qui se veut drôle
iron
fait pas r tout ça peine voil
jeisastnais pas pour lui il est pas
coupable donc il fait un communiqu
comme je savais que j'éta innocent c'est
pas pour autant que je ferais ce genre
de de blague parce que pour moi en fait
ça décrédibilise finalement ma défense
déjà d'avance et puis je trouve même que
c'est limite un manque de respect pour
le coup pour les victimes qui parfois
elles sont vraiment victimes tu vois
dans un autre cas c'estàd que c'est une
procédure qui a le mérite d'exister tu
la respectes même si tu es innocent et
là pour le coup ouais mais imagine qu'il
tous les mecs qui sont accusés qui sont
accusés à tort ou à raison ils prennent
ces TER grav en disant voilà je suis
terrassé et CER malus aussi tout
simplement se ta et attendre oui mais il
oui mais se terre parce comm gr bu il
est obligé de parler ça fait un énorme
buz il est obligé par sa carrière en
pause et là le fait en fait peux pas te
taire après ça tu es obligé ça le rend
détestable c'est pas une bonne tactique
d'accord JeanMichel n'est pas d'accord
non moi je suis pas d'accord avec toi on
présuge pas du tout des suites de
l'affaire mais je trouve c'est une façon
de ne pas mettre un pied dans le
tribunal médiatique qui s'est qui s'est
déclenché et c'est le fait de rester en
dehors il est sûr de son bon droit je
sais pas ce que donnera laffaire mais
voilà c'est une façon de montrer bien à
lui qui lui ressemble voilà qu'il se
sent complètement innocent des fait qu'
lui sont reproché et voilà c'est un peu
ironique mais il met pas le pied dans
avec les termes d'avocat mon avocat et
ce non il reste en dehors de ça moi
jeouve jeille moi je pense que ça
réveille justement au contraire la la le
tourbillon médiatique ça va déchaîner au
contraire les réseaux sociaux beaucoup
plus il assumera il a les épules solides
les ép TR qu'il a une manière de
dédramatiser non pas l'affaire mais le
fait que tous les jours c'est forc de
oui mais cette affaire c'est pas c'est
pas il y a pas un personnage de fiction
dans ce cas-là tu vois c'est pas un
romance qui passe là c'est la vraie vie
tous les jours quelquun est dans la SAU
tous les jours nouau me dans
la soit il n a que des gros ports dans
ce milieu et c'est à ce momentl très
regrettable là ce qu' dis c'est qu'il y
a des affaires comme ça tous les jours
et qu' au bout d'un moment voilà il s'en
amuse presque à moi ça me dégoûte parce
que a pas été accusé de vol mais de viol
donc je trouve que c'est c'est indécent
et puis on sait pas pour l'instant s'il
est innocent ou pas et moi je pr croire
une potentielle victime de viol que un
potentiel violeur donc je trouve que moi
ça me dégoûte ce qu'il qu'il dit
d'accord vous ça vous choque ch tu peux
pas rigoler de sujets comme ça Pedro
mais non mais c'est exactement ça c'est
là ce que tu dis Guillaume c'est que tu
pars du principe que c'est soit tout le
monde est innocent soit tout le monde
est coupable il y a toute une nuance tu
imagine bien que les gens les femmes ne
s'amusent pas à aller porter plainte et
à faire tout toutes ces procédures qui
sont traumatisantes par bon vous de
décider bien sûr que oui bien sûr que
oui mais quand toi tu tu es dans la
sauce comme lui il est dans la sauce et
ben tu essayes de faire profil bas et de
te montrer stratégique pour ta défense
tu ne cherches pas à faire de la
provocation parce que l'opinion publique
va se dire bon ben en fait tout le monde
est surpuissant les les mecs se cro
aessus des LO soit ne parlent pas soit
prennent un air très grave en disant
voilà je suis abattu je suis terrassé
c'est une manière de donner du crédit à
ce tribunal médiatique lui il a pris le
parti de dire je m'en fous je fais comme
si de rien était et je m'en amuse même
après peut-être de faire Guillaume là où
tu as raison effectivement il fait du
BBD B BD on l'attend là-dessus on
l'attend sur l'ironie on l'attend sur le
pas de côté sur l'humour et cetera il se
trouve que là en l'occurrence il y a
quand même une oui voilà le pas de côté
il se trouve que en l'occurrence là il y
a une jeune fille qui a é allé porter
plainte donc on sait pas dans quel état
elle se trouve cette jeune fille on sait
pas si c'est vrai ou pas peu importe
mais mais il y a plein de jeunes femmes
aussi qui sont des victimes qui sont
dans le cas de figure de cette jeune
femme et qui ont peut-être mal vécu ce
communiquer j'aimerais j'aimerais qu'on
moi je vous posaer une question revenir
sur les propos de de Kelly hier est-ce
que ça vous choque vous 58 ans 17 ans
même si légalement il y a pas de il y a
pas de voilà il y a pas de
contreindication est-ce que ça vous
choque 58 ans 17 ans dites la vérité on
se dit tout ici ou en fait c'est pas la
différence d'âge qui est parce que si
c'était 30 70 c'est différent mais là
c'est qu'à 17 ans on est encore très
naïf on n pas conscience de tout on est
parfois totalement immature donc là pour
le coup oui c'est le problème c'est pas
la différence c'est le fait que l'âge
est très bas donc c'est quoi en fait
l'âge moi je suis personne pour dire
ça moi pour moi à partir de 20 ans on
commence déjà à avir le sens des choses
avant 20 ans c'est un peu compliqué 17
ans c'est moi si tu as 60 ans et 19 ans
je me dis qu'il y a encore un problème
ça tu dis c'est par rapport 20
il dit ce qu' P voà non il dit ce qu'il
pense mais moi plus là j'ai haut plus je
me dis attention le curseur si le mec a
60 ans tu peux 25 30 c'est pas gênant ça
gêne pas mais 19 ans 18 ans ça gêne
c'est quand même c'est moi je partage je
partage ce dit k 17 ans moi moi moi
person pour la morale je Jouge pas du
tout Frédéric bbéé
voilà il a 58 ans qui a 58 ans ici 59
voilà g bon il il a ton âge à peu près
je te verrai pas avecun meuf de 17 ans
excuse-moi mais par exemple pa 24 ans ça
ça me choquerait pas tant que ça parce
que elle a la
maturité peut-être peut-être non non
mais 24 ans voilà non mais 17 ans c'est
vrai que 17 ans le 1
devant quand même c'est c'est après il
fait ce qu'il veut on dit voilà on juge
pas mais c'est vrai voilà 17 ans c'est
vrai que raison de plus raison de plus
pour faire profil bas même s'il est
innocent par la justice rien que parce
que cette jeune fille à 17 ans la blague
est d'autant plus je trouve c'est un
argument auquel j'ai même pas pensé mais
le fait qu' 1 ans c'est d'autant plus
mal placé je trouve de faire une blague
non mais après après moi dans ce que
disait Kelly hier elle disait 58 ans 17
ans 17 ans ça veut dire que 17 ans en
vrai tu es mineuras rien à lui dire norm
non mais auelà de ça c c'est tes parents
encore ils sont quand même à 17 ans tu
es pas complètement indépendant tu suis
désolé c'est tes parents qui voilà tu
visement chez tes parents tu tu racontes
tu racontes tu racontes peut-être des
truc à tes parents tes parents je sais
pas quelles sont tes relations mais
c'estàdire que je comprends ce qu'elle
veut dire
dans le truc où c'est vrai qu'aussi
quand les gars tu sors avec une meuf de
17 ans tu sais que tu c'est avoir des
problèmes mine de rien parce que c'est
c'est c'est quelqu'un qui qui voilà je
comprends c'est c'est une ado donc elle
décide pas toute seule elle sait pas
trop ce qu'elle fait elle peut
êtreluu c'est voilà 20 ans 19 ans je
trouve déjà 19 ans voilà c'est c'est
mineur 17 ans c'est ça aussi hein c'est
c'est c'est audelà de la majorité
sexuelle
mais c'est mur plan Léal compqué même si
elle est peut-être très mature bien évid
elle pourrait encore être à l'école
encore exa 17 ans tu es en
prèreè moi à 17 ans j'étais en 4e frère
après si l'histoire sil se marie s'ils
ont beaucoup d'enfants on dira qu'il y a
pas de problème en fait tout dépend
aussi l'issue de l'histoire aussi et
dans son dans son dernier livre
confession d'un hétérosexuel légèrement
dépassé il écrivit le désir masculin est
dangereux heureusement il y a des lois
ave B mais voilà le le le le truc il y a
des gens qui disent oui faut pas oublier
que la la la jeune fille éta était
consentante au départ c'est pas ce qu'on
dit on est pas dans un truc de loi on
est dans un truc de Kelly elle a dit
hier un truc elle a dit si tu veux aussi
t'étonnes pas que tu es des problèmes
quand tu tu as 58 ans et que tu sors
avec une meuf de 17 ans déjà la la jeune
fille de 17 ans euh voilà c'est vrai que
17 ans 58 ans c'est c'est c'est oui mais
après c il y a aussi des couples qui
tombent amoureux qui s'aiment qui F des
famill a diff non mais je dis
pas non mais non mais non mais moi c'est
juste le truc 17 ans je dis à partir de
1920 1920 tout passe en moi j'ai moi
j'ai j'ai des j'ai des gens que je
connais qui ont une énorme différence
d'â Mo j'ai moi j'ai 25 ans avec ma
chérie elle elle a pas 17 ans elle a 37
j'ai
62 Kelly elle a dit ce que tout le monde
pense la vérité c'est que si tu as une
fille de 17 ans une sœur de 17
ans de 58 ans un problème je vais voir
le mec de 58 ans ouis bah oui p
mais tu vois du coup Guillaume raison
plus pour ne pas pour ne pas faire la
blague oui c'est pas le même sujet mais
si pourtant c'est la base oui 17 ans
c'est choquant moi même 19 ans les mecs
moi j'ai moi moi ma fille a 19 ans elle
me ramène un mec qui a 58 ou 60 ans qui
est plus vieux que moi je dire on prends
toi qui c'est quoi ton projet ouais mais
c'est le projet tu parles de projet
c'est pas c'est 17 ans 17 ans moi comme
m' dit GG 17 ans tu es tu es en
[Musique]
vérité tu votes pas tuis pas tu en FA
casino avec ta meuf bah ou hein c'est un
cas particulier là on est pas que sur
innocent ou coupable on est sur comme
vous l'avez dit c'est la
moralité moi j'ai 25 ans mais je l'ai
rencontré j'avais 30 ans 30 ans j'ai la
tête sur les épaules je sais où j'en
suis quoi ça rien à voir rien à voir
voilà voilà demain je te dis voilà
Pascal elle sentve qu'un mec de de 70
ans ça ça me choque pas mais c'est vrai
ou pour d'autres raisons à la limite
chacun pense ce qu'il veut et même
Pascal sort même avec un mec de 20 ans
ça me choque pas ça choque moi quand
c'est ça choque pas tu sors avec un mec
de 20 Ansah fais-toi plaisir la cougar
là la cougar mais c'est vrai faistoi
plaisir non mais alors on est d'accord
s'endescend oui c'est ce qu'on dit tous
ce soir non on dit pas tous c'est qu'on
c'est pas tous
commun par
communiqu qu'est-ce que tu en penses de
ce queelle a dit Kelly toi moi je suis
pas en désaccord avec elle moi c'est 17
ans c'est c'est exactement comme vous
c'est 17 ans qui me c'est moi j'ai une
sœur de 17 ans ouis parce que le
problème c'est ça il faut se mettre à la
place une sœur de 17 ans elle te dit il
y a un gars de 58 ans défoncer déjà le
gars je vais l'appeler bah oui direc
frère comment ça se fait que tu chébr ma
sœur non mais c'est vrai pas obligé tu
vas lui dire c'est quoi le bail tu vois
ou pas donc après si elle te dit elle
amoureuse de lui qu'est-ce que tu veux
faire non c'est si l'homme vous allez le
voir il vous dit c'est la femme de ma
vie je suis amoureuse de lui je veux
faire ma vie avec lui c'est pas pareil
que si vous êtes un
ta le nez
fracturé comprends je comprends même pas
qu'un homme s'autorise à à à à regarder
des femmes de 17 ans des filles de 17
ans avec mais tout le monde regarde
filles pas non mais là il faut pas faut
pas les mecs être dans la morale en fait
moi moi quand je dis ça je pense à à à
moi voilà si je me dis si j'ai une
petite sœur de 17 ans voilà voilà c'est
comme toi tu penses pareil voilà c'est
pas j'aime pas moi j'aime pas les mecs
qui font la morale excuse-moi arrê d'
arrêtons d'être hypocrite on connait
plein d'hommes qui ont beaucoup d'argent
qui son tous
beaucoupoup Jerte
dire toi tu es jeune tu es pas concerné
je te dis juste quand les mecs on même à
32 ans jamaisah moi je ne m'autoriserai
jamais à avoir une relation de séduction
avec une fille de 17
ans ve par que dans ma tête je trouve ça
malsin et je trouve c'est
problématique 20 ans tu déjà sorti a des
20 ans oui oui mais à 29 à 28 mais après
20 ans c'est pas pareil 17 ans c'est
mineur
et quand les hommes divorcent
généralement c'est pas pour être avec
des femmes plus é ou le
GE tout mour de la table trouve ça la lo
c'est 15 ans et 3
moisme dire c'est pas pour ça que moi je
considère qu'une fille 15 ans et 3 mois
c'est une
femme non mais c'est comme ça ça c'est
c'est ça peut être à changer parce que
moi je pense que ça serait bien ça
serait bien de non parce que parce Queen
fait parce qu'en fait on le sait les les
ados à 14 15 ans mais entre eux alorsou
parce que 15 ans par exemple et 3 mois
ave quelqu'un de 70 ans ou mais en fait
c'est 15 et 18 nor c'est pas choquant 15
et 19 c'est pas choquant 17 et 58 désolé
il y a un problème non mais c'est c'est
je vois ce que je veux dire après c'est
comment tu considères moi moi voilà une
meuf de une fille de 15 ans je la
considère pas comme une femme tu dis
voilà c'est
c'est la loi c'est une femme alors là en
l'occurrence il y aurait deux problèmes
une femme pour moi je considère une
fille comme une femme à partir de de 20
ans Mo pas comme vous 19 ans 20 ans dans
lesempes de posk il y aurait à la fois
le problème moral et aussi5s ouais et
aussi le problème légal parce que
l'écart l'écart entre 15 ans et 60 70
ans serait jugé comme étant pas conforme
à la légalité voilà voilà il y aurait
les deux là là il a les de T l' c'est l'
c'est pas t c'est la différence il r
quoi il disent non mais par parce
qu'elle est mineure attention parelle
est mine la finalité c'est que peu
importe si il est finalement blanchi ou
non elle a quand même fait cette
démarche là donc c'est c'est quelqu'un
qui souffre quand même peu importe
qu'elle le fasse pour je ne sais quelle
raison c'est qu'elle a mal vécu quelque
chose bien sûr
donc et l'enquête se poursuit
téléspectateur je crois qu'on a
été alors je sais pas il qu'il a un
problème avec les sondages donc on va
voir si c'est les vraies réponses mais
non apparemment c'est non donc 80 % des
gens trouvent pas ça indécent les
chéries